ah gentlemen the entertainment is here
everybody I'd like to introduce you to
Elizabeth hi guys
I hear there's an important meeting here
I'm not really into strippers and you
know what I find sexy
Pam's art she's an artist and I
appreciate that it's very moving and
sexy the art he's right there
there is absolutely not that's all
okay all right I'll do it yeah let's do
it let's do this thing
yeah oh here we go all right not bad not
bad you smell nice like tide smell like
tide detergent
here's Tide detergent I have a
girlfriend I bet she be jealous yeah she
probably yes she would be doing okay
excuse me
snick please stop it stop it turn up the
music this is wrong this is wrong this
is wrong I have a girlfriend ah and you
are engaged and I'm sure you have a
boyfriend in prison or something so
let's just clear out okay
shame on you go back to mark Elizabeth I
want you to sit here when the phone
rings answer it you want me to answer
phones with my clothes on we hired you
for three hours work and we're gonna get
it well where I live your poster thank
you
you